[Musik]
wie ihr erahnen könnt geht es heute um
mein team und ich will jetzt unser team
vor genau also am anfang war ich da habe
ich ganz alleine die videos gemacht
junge hat überlegt es gibt irgendwie
keine koch und back videos also mache
ich das zum stolz meinen freunden zur
verfügung
und ich habe dann einfach eine kamera
aufgestellt für eine kleine
digitalkamera hat nur damals noch nicht
so gutes smartphone 89 gestellt die mama
dabei meine beste freundin hat die
kamera gehalten
und da hab ich mir eigentlich schon
kurze zeit später ein stativ gekauft und
dann immer wieder die kamera selber
umgestellt damals ohne mikrofon noch ein
bisschen ja es war knapp vor 67 jahren
und es waren ja immer auch leute immer
spekuliert dass ich der kameramann ja
manche aber ist ja und dann habe ich mir
gedacht da muss ja nichts gedacht
eigentlich gar nichts getan
das ist einfach alles passiert das
wahlfach hobby macht man sprach zu
kochen und zu backen und dann noch die
menschen dafür zu begeistern das ist
eigentlich das was mir am meisten spaß
macht und die rezepte denke ich mir aus
und wie gesagt am anfang habe ich dann
noch die kamera selber gemacht den
schnitt selber auf windows movie maker
das kind ständig aber das war ein
schnittprogramm auf manipulation einfach
kauft es nicht ist es widerlich das
programm die wirklich kostenlos
ja und ja so habe ich dann wieder videos
angefangen und irgendwann hatten wir
auch mal kontakt und regionalen
fernsehen und so weiter also bei uns um
die ecke von jeder autos logisch zum
regionalen
dezember und aus bielefeld sie haben
keine regionalen sender ja und da haben
wir dann eigentlich das erste team
kennen gelernt das war der franken aber
immerhin frank reden ein anderes mal
heute geht es nämlich um den marius
[Musik]
ja und zwar ist dieses video jetzt nicht
nur eine teamvorstellung
das werden wir wirklich paypal machen
also schritt für schritt weil jeder hat
es verdient in unserem team ist und auch
unsere freunde
außerdem fragt er immer danach wer ist
alles bei euch im team wie entstehen die
videos und jetzt machen wir so ein
bisschen wie ein des sehens wie alles
entstanden ist wer bei uns mit dabei ist
intim und ja wie das einfach so bei uns
ab 9
ja und marius würde mir gerne anfangen
weil es einem maße das hat etwas ganz
ganz besonderes weil das hat auch mit
unserem neuen buch zu tun und nicht mit
meinem neuen buch ich hab ja nichts
gemacht und dann nehme ich lieber
mehrheitlich ja ich halte fest dass sie
über den bauch nicht da muss ich den
baum hier einziehen
das ist neue buch das ist das heißt food
fotografie hat nichts mit höchsten zu
tun sondern mit fotos und apps immer mit
ja genau und und auf jeden fall hat es
damit zu tun und da marius hat es
zusammen mit der salih zusammen gemacht
genau und am anfang habe ich ja auch die
bilder selber gemacht das sieht man auch
die ist die sache dann auch wirklich so
war es mit der digitalkamera und dann
ich meine wir hatten hat damals diese
smartphone von nichts es gibt es erst
seit ein paar jahren und klar jetzt
kriege ich auch mit meinem handy
ich sage jetzt nicht die marke aber mit
meinem handy kriege ich auch toll finden
aber trotzdem braucht mir das gewisse
etwas um bilder zu machen und als der
marius ungefähr vor vier jahren zu uns
kam hatte übrigens galileo entdeckt im
fernsehen genau das werde letztlich
gedacht sitz mädchen dieser junge frau
dieser anfang macht schlechte böse aber
tolle video aber sie spricht unseren
direkt denn es kommt ja auch zeit genau
der unseren angeschriebene marius und an
dem tag wo damals bei uns war das erste
shooting gemacht
genau und da war dann wirklich war war
es wird nicht ganz cool ich finde halt
mein marius war das tolle als wenn
marios kennengelernt habe der war so so
so extrem höflich so und wo ja keine
fehler machen wie man halt so ist im
juni an
erstes shooting gleich am ersten
kennenlern tag gebracht hat kommt ihm
raus in den wald
in der küche das sind auch die kinder
rosam ihre mit dem stimmung das waren
die ersten bürger weiter die ersten
bilder die am ersten tag entstanden sind
weil wir mussten ja irgendwie wissen
passt so passt es nicht keine ahnung wir
haben noch nie mit einem fotografen
gearbeitet und es toll war dass sich
weit von uns weg war und uns schon
kannte und das ist ja echt so toll
gemacht was nicht mehr ihm beeindruckt
war
das war ja wie bei uns das ist einfach
leidenschaftlich anfangen hat als auch
wirklich so aus dem hobby heraus hat
dass ich halt für die fotografie
interessiert und wieder aquatic gebildet
und das war eigentlich das was er gesagt
hat ist genau also oftmals ist nun mal
keine verhältnisse eine ausbildung
machen
du machst an der ausbildung als
kfz-mechaniker alle konnte als konditor
wenn dein papa gesagt hat macht
irgendwas dann machst du dann deine drei
jahre ausbildung hat aber gar keinen
bock drauf gehabt du hast trotzdem
gemacht und kann natürlich sagen ich bin
konditor aber wenn wir konditor wirst
aus leidenschaft dann machst du das ganz
ganz anders das ist ganz ganz anders an
die sache ran
du wirst weiterkommen du probierst dinge
aus weil es da deine leidenschaft ist
und so ist bei marius der hat es nicht
gelernt aber er hat diese unglaubliche
leidenschaft und das war das was uns
beeindruckt habe damals bei marius und
wir haben ihn gefragt ob er weiter
zusammen arbeiten möchte und zeit in den
letzten vier jahren haben wir wie viele
bücher gemachte mahnung zusammen 44
bücher 5 mit dem hier fünf meine kräfte
war das rezepte für kinder hat danach
kamen danach kam
dieses charity genau und fremd und dann
noch die türkische küche wirklich
orientalische küche und ich jetzt das
dritte bis fünfte muss und welche und
das ding halt einfach die leute auch mal
gefragt haben wie kann man diese fotos
machen gemacht wird dass und allem drum
und dran was man die tipps und tricks
dahinter aber ich denke auch seriös
erfolg hat auch mit diesen bildern zu
tun ganz ganz klar weil tolle bilder
werden gern angesehen und jeder von uns
ist der fotograf weil wenn man sie
irgendwo in dem restaurant ich davon ist
jeder fokussiert auf ersten krankheit
also anfang an was auch immer so gemacht
ich war halt also ich bin halt fürs
essen anrichten zuständig und deshalb
fürs foto machen und er hat praktisch
motive gesucht und ich hab halt jemanden
gesucht der fotografieren kann ja also
ich hab eigentlich jemand gesucht aber
er kam halt und er hat eigentlich auch
niemanden besuchs war halt so einfach
gibt nur ausgesuchte hat dennoch
gefunden und jetzt machte marius ganz
einfach der macht halt sally kocht und
backt oder pakistan macht die bilder hat
aber macht aber auch die zweite kamera
wieder seitlich kommt irgendwie richten
dann halt das essen zusammen und das set
und suchen das equipment zusammen
ich meine er ist jetzt auch schuld dass
ich zum messe geworden bin weshalb man
das alles macht auch wenn dann ja und
wie gesagt hat natürlich weit gebrachte
marius und es ist echt wahnsinn
und jetzt habe dieses buch
herausgebracht hat er mir dass herr
jesus buch gemacht und das besondere an
diesem buch ist nicht reicht dann nichts
danke ich hab nichts an dem buch gemacht
wegen ich nicht tragen einfach schritt
für schritt erklärt für anfänger oder
auch fortgeschrittene wie man von
snapfish zum fertigen stollen foto kommt
und das ganze einmal mit kamera und eben
auch allem mit dem handy genau das gerät
ist nicht wichtig sich eine teure kamera
zu kaufen du kannst jetzt teuerste und
beste kamera haben aber wenn du kein
auge hast für die fotografie und kanoute
herrscht das motiv dann ist ja auch die
teuerste kamera nichts und man kann
wirklich auch mit dem einfachsten handy
und mittlerweile sind wirklich alle
handys super ausgestattet mit nach super
kamera hat die iphones mit dem mit dem
portrait modus usw
aber wenn man da kein auge dafür hat und
nicht weiß wie weiter hintergrund
wechseln
was oder wie das objekt belichtet sein
muss dann nützt dir halt auch echt die
beste kamera nix und daher da sind halt
echt die ganzen tipps und tricks drin
und ich denke das buch ist auch echt
toll für alle die sich nicht nur für die
fotografie interessieren sich auch
wirklich zur fotografie allgemein aber
aber das mit schwerpunkt fotografie und
vor allem dass ein paar kohle durch
selbst dh man muss sich mal alles kaufen
man kann in sachen selber machen das
heißt kinder gründe selber basteln
dann hatten indes softbox alleine die
außentanks kartons markt noch den großen
unterschied gibt die auch food stylist
und das haben wir hier nicht also ich
bin auch kein fußball ist es auch nicht
denn fußball ist es oftmals so dass man
einfach das essen so herrichtet das ist
perfektes foto aussieht mit haag mit
haarschaum mit rasiergel keine ahnung
was mit erdöl und so weiter und das
machen wir halten also alles was wir
fotografieren können wir auch danach
noch essen genau und ich tue sachen
immerhin richten hinrichten heißen
schwierig zu essen immerhin richten
unter marius zu errichten auf jeden fall
ein ganz ganz tolles buch wirklich das
sind keine rezepte drin im gegenteil ist
eine rezepte drin anders
fürs foto genau und jeder der der
vielleicht blogger ist oder einfach
coole bilder verschicken möchte jetzt
hier wirklich in umfangreich sind über
390 seiten richtig ernst 260 seien zwar
und es stimmt 93 war das andere buch ja
unschön mannschaft aus dem arischen
erzählen wir uns gefunden hast genau war
es auf jeden fall jemand der kräfte und
der kürzung zum team
und jetzt lassen meine marius sprechen
richtig das ist unglaublich wie du
einfach meine übergänge zum nächsten
schnitt dabei das letzte wort haben muss
haben wir echt ok also jetzt kommt
marius
[Musik]
wir haben uns eigentlich kennengelernt
haben wir uns eigentlich kennengelernt
vor vier jahren war das glaube ich und
da habe ich einfach auf der couch
gesessen so ein bisschen durch fernseh
gesetzt und dann habe ich so einen
badischen dialekt gehört dann dachte ich
das ist doch bestimmt die aus der nähe
da schauen wir mal zu damit bestreiten
dass die leichen für unsere was ich von
gestern vor sozusagen bistum geht es
übrigens nicht weil er ja ich wusste
dass das sagt ja ich wollte mich auch
schon sagen jedoch das buch jetzt nicht
wissen warum weil sie böse sind genau
die bezahlung ihrer mitarbeiter nicht
anständig und keine steuern höhere
steuern genau und die rechnung her kommt
aus luxemburg ja und zwar gibt es nur
online bei uns oder bei interspar in
österreich oder bei bloß los was
unterscheidet eigentlich unser buch von
anderen fotografen büchern ich meine es
gibt schon genügend
also es gibt ja schon ziemlich viele
fotografien bücher aber allgemein ist es
oft so dass immer um den heißen brei
herumgeredet wird dann habe ich mir
gedacht eigentlich soll man den heißen
brei fotografieren
also wird in dem buch gezeigt wie man
den heißen brei fotografiert und nicht
so viel herum geredet und jetzt sagen
wenn hat auf den punkt gebracht also ich
finde so ein ewig langer text shrek
teilt immer gleich ab wenn man es schön
zusammenfasst und viele bilder dazu
macht dann macht viel mehr spaß genau
fertig nun das buch also das buch ist in
erster linie natürlich für leute die
sich für fotografie allgemein
interessieren nicht nur jetzt die food
fotografie und alle leute die eben gerne
kochen und backen und eben auch mal ein
foto machen wollen weil manchmal sieht
das essen einfach so gut aus dass man
fotografieren muss und dann ist doch
schön wenn man das richtig gut machen
kann und mit dem buch denke ich kann das
jeder schnell und einfach lernen
ja wir werden ja oft gefragt wie oft wie
ein rezept machen und ich mache so ein
rezept wirklich im video zum ersten mal
also oftmals sind auch sachen die ich
vorher noch nie gegessen haben oder
nicht probiert habe und dann stelle ich
mich hin sagt okay heute mache ich jetzt
zum beispiel eine sachertorte
ich habe ich zwar vorher schon gegessen
aber ich mache mir wirklich im video zum
ersten mal und diese eine torte die ich
dann im video backe die wird halt auch
fotografiert also da wird kein zweites
oder drittes exemplar hergestellt
sondern diese eine die jetzt dann und
wir filmen dann zuerst das rezept und
dann wird zum schluss der anfang
also am ende des drehtages kommt der
anfang fürs video
deswegen habe ich mir dann schon das
fertige objekt und dann bauen wir schon
das set auf genau dann sowie schon mal
ein untergrund aus den hintergrund so
ein bisschen dekorationen und richtig
schon mal so ein bisschen her und dann
fotografieren wir erst einmal die torte
im ganzen so von oben von der seite
perspektivisch und so weiter oder auch
im bild für samuel zum beispiel für
youtube und danach geht es dann einfach
angeschnitten entweder direkt im video
oder eben am sep also dass er dann
praktisch am set sehr schöne an schneide
bilder haben und dann meistens ja wenn
es von dir kommt schon super aus und da
muss man nicht mehr viel fuß teilen aber
wenn es halt schon eine weile steht dann
müssen wir halt auch mal irgendwie ein
bisschen mit back translate oder so
nachhilfe aber immer nur mit natürlichen
sachen dass wir da nicht das war aber
noch essen kann weil das ja das
wichtigste
ja das licht muss natürlich auch gemacht
werden das licht ist allgemein
eigentlich das wichtigste finde ich und
da arbeiten wir meistens mit der
mischung aus tageslicht und led lampen
und ja dann wird es halt schon mal ein
bisschen eingestellt und damit dann
alles fertig ist wenn das gericht kommen
weil dann ist keine zeit zu verlieren
ja und danach wenn es ein fotografiertes
und jeder bei uns bekommt und torten
paket mit nach hause der traum der ist
nicht so gerne süß ist deswegen dem das
immer mit für seine schwiegereltern und
marius ist du gerne süßes aber bei uns
steht im arbeitsvertrag drin
ich muss mein torten paket mit nach
hause nehmen punkt und ich hatte ja ganz
lange ein suppen verbot von murat also
ich mache ja gerne auch gesunde sachen
suppen salate gemüse und der murat hat
dann irgendwann gesagt ch auf suppen zu
machen
das sieht einfach furchtbar aus und ich
meine meine fotos anhalt auch nicht so
gut aus aber es ist ja auch einfacher
eine tolle torte und tolles motiv zu
fotografieren aber ich finde die kunst
liegt darin auch mal was nicht so schön
ist appetitlich herzurichten wie zum
beispiel der maronen suppe oder
linsensuppe oder halt mal so ein eintopf
oder gulasch und ich meine es ja schon
gerichtet die jetzt nicht so appetitlich
auf den ersten blick aussehen die zwar
super lecker schmecken und auch tollen
alltag passen aber ja und dann ist es
einfach die kunst diese sachen
appetitlich zu fotografieren und das
schafft er auch und ich meine wenn man
sowas haben wir schon auch mit käse
überbacken ist weil der käse wieder
ziemlich schnell fest das heißt werden
wir immer das problem machen wir jetzt
erst die fotos oder das video zu ende
genauso wichtig dass es noch warm ist
damit man auch sieht wieder eine so
schöne fäden ziehen so dass natürlich
appetitlicher dann doch mal was meistens
aber fünf minuten früher auf dann machen
wir die bilder nur die schönen anrichte
bilder und dann noch mal rein in den
backofen damit war am wochenende vom
video ja sozusagen muss man beachten
aber wir machen nicht nur einmal eben
dieses buch aufgebaut am anfang geht es
über food fotografie basic genau in den
basics erkläre ich halt so einfach mal
den ablauf wie es die deshalb von a bis
z so gemacht wird und später wird es
dann alles nochmal detailliert erklärt
aber am anfang erstmal erst mal den
überblick hat was ebenso gemacht wird
wie man sich inspiriert wie man ideen
sucht und wie man das dann eben auch
alles umsetzt dann wird er ist ein
technisch dann geht es über kamera und
technik also im kapitel kamera und
technik wird eben gezeigt wie man mit
der kamera umgeht wie man sie einstellt
aber auch so fragen wie welche kamera
soll ich mir holen zum beispiel das
werde ich oft gefragt weil die leute
eben sich dann auch meine große kamera
kaufen wollen die spiegelreflex oder
systemkamera und da gibt es natürlich
erst mal viele fragen und das wird auch
im buch erklärt worauf man achten muss
was man braucht und eben dass man auch
mit dem smartphone gute fotos machen
kann wenn man eben jetzt nicht so viel
geld hat für eine richtige kamera
hustinx über die schulter geschaut
gibt's da einblicke in unsere wut fotos
also im nächsten kapitel kann man uns
über die schulter schauen einfach wie so
ein fotoshooting von a bis z abläuft da
sieht man dann eben den aufbau was man
währenddessen beachten muss ein paar
tipps und tricks und ganz hinten im buch
eben auch die nachbearbeitung damit man
eben auch sie die man die ganzen schönen
fotos sortiert und eben bearbeitet und
eben noch ein stück besser machen kann
im kapitel food fotografie lernen könnt
ihr zum beispiel erfahren wie man
überhaupt essen anrichtet welche
requisiten passend zu diesem rezept
welche farben passen gut zueinander und
das kommt in diesem kapitel echt richtig
gut zur geltung haben dann haben wir
noch ein kapitel mit durchmesser genau
das ist glaube ich mein lieblings
kapitel 198 super kreativ zahlt ja weil
hintergründe muss man sich ja nicht
immer kaufen sondern
die eben auch selbst machen und dann
kann man sie so machen wie man sieht ja
dass der vorteil grad bei dem buch soll
ihren fans da war mir ist super kreativ
also da haben wir zebra hintergründe
gemalt wassermelonen dann die kleinen
affen erinnert sich an die neue kleider
koches misslichen machen wir das
kinderlied mit rein wer hat die
kokosnuss geklaut
also haben wir glaube ich echt immer
ziemlich kreativ und wenn es dem einen
nicht einfällt fest dem anderen ein also
da nicht immer ganz wichtig einfach
alles auszuprobieren ergänzen und nicht
oh ja das ist echt und vor allem ist
immer so liebevoll gestaltet und wenn
man hintergrund oder untergrund selber
macht dann hat man halt auch den vorteil
das ist ein unikat ist dann kann man
auch selber genau das so machen wie man
das möchte
genau ja und danach kommt einfach noch
das kapitel wie war so ein bisschen
erzählen wie wir zueinander gefunden
haben und so weiter und gesungen was
noch heute schon ein bisschen an
geschnitten haben
also alles in allem ein richtig tolles
buch nicht nur für food fotografen
sondern wirklich für alle die tolle
motive fotografieren wollen oder auch
nicht so tolle motive und trotzdem ein
tolles wetter machen wollen ich denke
für jeden der sich ein bisschen für
fotografie interessiert wird es ein
super hilfe sein und egal ob anfänger
oder fortgeschrittene
ja ich denke dass für jeden was dabei
macht den abschluss machen so weiß schon
warum du kein redakteur geworden sich ja
ein produktions und aufnahmeleiter
vielleicht zu gut aussehen auf jeden
fall gibt es das buch jetzt was mich
jetzt qvc nein
das buch gibt es auch morgen nicht nur
jetzt das buch gibt es morgen auch noch
jetzt natürlich auch wenn jetzt habe ich
auf dem shop geht berichtet dass wir
zusammen sind jetzt einfach alles
rausschneiden jedenfalls ist dieses
video der staat zu unserer team reihe
also wir möchten euch einfach unser team
vorstellen angefangen bei marius dann
geht es weiter über fragen marcel sehr
mark die machen ja echt alle der traum
als jeder macht wirklich bei uns super
super tolle arbeit ich kann jetzt nicht
alle namen aufzählen aber wir haben auch
nicht so ein mega großes team als ist
wirklich ein kleines familiäres team im
moment überlegen wir uns gerade noch war
die weihnachtsfeier machen wird auch
wieder lustig und nicht europa wir
wollen europa porsche wir machen das mit
übernachtung ok ja und vielleicht auch
mit karaoke bar
wir wollten euch erstmal die geschichte
erzählen und ab jetzt gibt es auch das
buch im onlineshop deswegen haben wir
auch noch nicht rein zu den
autogrammstunden hatten das auch schon
dabei genau viele haben sich das auch
echt schon geholt und sich viele tipps
und tricks geholt haben das buch ist wie
alle anderen bücher wird in deutschland
gedruckt machen papier auf der region
und das ist uns auch immer sehr wichtig
gedruckt hat es arbeitsdruck das auch
mal sagen unser freund toni unter
drucker karl-heinz und jawohl es
punktgenau
übrigens ich bin ohne spaß ich gelernter
drucktechnologie nennt sich das ich habe
das wirklich gelernt drucker wirklich
ein cooler beruf könnte auch machen also
dass sie am markt zum beispiel die sehr
mag zum beispiel macht was macht dass
jemand sie am markt der macht aber das
war eine ganz tolle geschichte der
designer
ja und er ist ein ganz ganz junge
designer unter frank was macht der
franck der frage der schneiden die
videos dann war der allererste der bei
uns angefangen hat wenn es nach franck
bleibt war dem regionalen fernsehsender
da kommt zu uns am besten kuchen torten
und frank ist auch cool und aber marcel
der marcel versteht keine ironie
er versteht keine ironie wir versuchen
uns im beizubringen
er hat seine ausbildung bei uns gemacht
und er macht jetzt
das team jetzt schon ja die anderen
sagen dass ich macht heiß unglaublich da
machst du die leute heißt ich gehe schon
mal aber er steht keine ironie ja dann
haben wir noch einen tomtom ist auch ein
kameramann und zwar stehe einer kamera
kann jetzt ich komme jetzt prüfe aber
jetzt sachen erzähle während der kamera
steht jetzt kann ich machen
die canon buchgewinnen genau das mache
jetzt noch ich habe es noch ein buch
heraus
oder 5 wenn ihr genau sagt mir einfach
habe ich liebe es in die länge
okay sagt mir einfach welchen beruf hat
man im rat gelernt genau genau schreibt
es rein unter den ersten fünf das kann
ich mache sonst so schnell einfach ich
los einfach fünf leute aus welchen beruf
hatte murat gelernt schreibt es in die
kommentare egal ob bei facebook
instagram oder bei youtube und der recht
tatsächlich druck stand zu sein und wenn
sie mehr vom team sehen wollen auch
kommend genau wenn ihr mehr vom thron
sehen wollt oder euch einen ja schreiben
wir zuerst sehen genau wer malt zuerst
hin aus dem team
vielleicht habt ihr euch niemand
verliebt schreibt ist das zeigen ja auf
jeden fall
wie gesagt ich hab da macht man
gewinnspiel kaputt wir können ein ihr
könnt ein buchgewinn fünf stück könnte
gewinn also nicht nicht ein und kann
alle fünf gewinnen sondern fünf können
jeweils ein buchgewinn schreibe ich
schreibe mit dem die kommentare was hat
gelernt so und wer nix schreit er wird
blockiert okay also macht es gut und
holte das buch jetzt gibt es im
onlineshop kann steht ja noch so machen
ok macht so das buch aus
und so sehe ich auch so bist du groß